what I'm going to talk about today
relates somewhat to my work but not
entirely to my work and I'll make that
clear as we go along I want to start by
mentioning something totally different
to begin with I have been supported by
government agencies since 1971 mostly
the NIH and I think many other people in
this room have also been supported by
the NIH and other government agencies
over the years if I make a rough
calculation maybe a penny or two of your
taxes or let's say that approximately a
hundred million people who pay taxes
every year in the US was devoted to
supporting my research so instead of
waiting till the end of the lecture and
showing a fancy list of all the people
who supported my research and the people
involved I'm simply going to say thank
you very much for your support I
appreciate it even if you're not aware
of it it was very important to me over
the years and thank you okay so I'm
going to talk about the origin of life
and contrary to what I usually say the
beginning of lectures to undergraduates
here I'm not going to solicit generally
questions from the audience during the
lecture because I'm going to say some
outrageous things some of you may think
and I don't want to get too involved
until the end of the lecture to try and
answer any questions you have first of
all one could ask some questions about
life itself and perhaps I should start
by giving a very simple definition of
what I think life is that is to say
living organism we should take energy
from the environment around it to
sustain itself that it must reproduce
itself exactly that as a genetic
material must be
used exactly from one generation to the
next that's my limit of definition one
can add various other things and I'll
probably mention some of them later but
right now that is my definition now one
could ask some questions about life and
I think that some of them and in your
minds perhaps might require
philosophical answers to these questions
let me state right now that I do not
believe there's a philosophy of life
even though I have met people who say
they are philosophers of life I just
don't accept that period and if you ask
me questions about the philosophy of
life I'll refuse to answer them or all
grunt next question one can ask is
obviously one can think about the
scientific origin of life and we'll talk
a little bit about that and I do think
about it from time to time but not very
often
but people try to do some experiments in
which they try and reproduce some of the
basic features that have to do with the
origin of life in fact Jack szostak who
I think will be here next week is going
to talk about certain very primitive
pockets made of lipids through which
molecules can enter and that's supposed
to be some has some relevance to the
origin of life and you can do that and
there are many people who do experiments
of that kind but one question that can
certainly be asked is what relation do
they have to the origin of life I mean
you can do an experiment today but and
you can get an answer to your experiment
but what does that have to do with what
happened let's say four and a half
billion years ago it's not clear that
you ever will have a direct answer to
that
but what you will learn may help you
think about what may have happened
billions of years ago so I think the
people who wish to do those experiments
should and I will say something else
about experiments of that kind that is
to say regardless of what you may think
about it we are all problem solvers that
is if you're in your kitchen and you
drop a kitchen tool or a valuable coin
that rolls behind your refrigerator
you're going to wonder how to get it out
do I have to move the refrigerator what
else do I have to do but you're going to
spend some time thinking about that and
I don't think that's very unusual we
tend to do that no matter what field
we're in we try to solve problems and
this is another problem that we try to
look at and think about in a creative
ways now you can ask yourself where did
life originate and there are possibly
two answers to that first of all if you
speak to geo chemists who study ancient
times they will give you or they will
give you their estimate of what
chemicals existed on the earth billions
of years ago and whether or not those
chemicals can contribute to the origin
of life in fact that's one possibility
that these chemicals came into existence
and somehow and we'll talk about it they
were organized into molecules that we
recognize today but Frances quicken and
Leslie Orgel some years ago and thinking
about this problem decided that there
were some aspects of the chemistry of
making essential components of one of
the molecules that carry information was
too difficult and had to be carried out
under very exotic conditions and they
sort of gave up on this idea of life
originating on earth
however the question is and so they
proposed another solution which I'll get
to in a second but the question is if
they gave up on Earth then they must
have considered a similar origin of life
somewhere else because this is the only
so to speak life that we know about and
they thought about that and he proposed
another term I think the term had
already existed called panspermia and
the idea was that life originated
somewhere else in the universe not on
earth not in our earth in fact we know
that there are meteorites that have
landed on earth that actually came from
other planets apparently there are some
meteorites that have been identified as
coming from Mars that is to say there is
a tremendous meteorite crash on Mars
some of the fragments flew out into
space and landed on earth and you can
look at carbonaceous meteorites that
occurred in various places on earth
summon for example and Antartica and
analyze them closely and sandra
Pizzarelli
arizona state university published a
paper in PNAS recently in which she
showed a spectrum of hydrocarbons that
were found in this meteorite and there's
a tremendous variety of hydrocarbons
some of them seemingly having something
to do with the origin of life however I
feel that's rather a tenuous description
of where life came from it's not
apparent that it came from somewhere
else if it did one must have had one
bacterium supposedly land on earth and
then generate for millions of
generations to ultimately leave to the
creatures that we know evolved since
that time I think to me that's very
unlikely and I will give some
I will simply cite some data recently
that shows that as I said before the
purines and pyrimidines basis can be
made quite simply okay so I'm going to
show a number of slides and some of them
are old slides and some of them I will
try and indicate where they came from
this slide appeared in a journal science
maybe 10 or 12 years ago and it was in a
review article on the origin of the
universe and let me just go through it
very quickly right there we have this
very planet that's filled with red
indicated that was very fiery and
supposedly that was the origin of the
planet of this planet at that time so
that's four and a half billion years ago
so the time from the president has
indicated here in billions of years then
after a while this fiery planet slowed
down a bit and I'll get to that in a
minute and we have something with a
stable hydrosphere that is to say the
sky and the ocean had supposedly stable
components to it and we'll have to talk
about that 4.2 billion years ago then we
had prebiotic chemistry that is to say
some of the molecules that were
important and what we think is important
in life are illustrated here but that
doesn't mean anything
so they were present then about four
billion years ago we had supposedly the
pre RNA world and you have one molecule
splitting into two as it replicates for
eight and one of course we don't know
that this happened
but that is four billion years ago and
then we have the RNA world which I will
talk about a little bit and then we have
the first DNA protein life and we don't
know how this happened yet but anyway
we'll say that this happened and then we
have the diversification of life so here
we have a simple evolutionary tree
that's just indicated
doesn't matter what's shown from 3.6
billion years ago to the prison so
that's a very broad description of what
went on now I think it's important to
ask some very simple questions and these
you might think are trivial questions in
fact this slide was made about eight
years ago
when I had to deliver a lecture to a
number of standing high school students
and this is the questions that one asked
so this would be the stable hydrosphere
what was the nature of the oceans were
they all water what was the chemical
nature of the oceans what particular
chemical compounds were in the oceans at
that time we're all were they all
oxygenated compounds we we don't know we
have to know these things what was the
nature of the sky how much oxygen was in
the sky or methane or carbon dioxide
this is very important in terms of
understanding the metabolism what we
think is the beginning of life then the
temperature is also very important were
the oceans that let's say ninety degrees
centigrade which seems unlikely
during supposedly stable hydrosphere or
were they down around 37 degrees which
is our body temperature and how about
electrical discharge because we know
that electrical discharge in terms of
lightning perhaps can affect various
biological reactions so we're really
thinking here about ultraviolet
radiation which we know is important in
stimulating many chemical reactions that
were interested in and finally the time
how much time can we spend on thinking
about the original chemical world in
terms of kinetics we understand about
various reactions now this slide is from
a paper that
existed in nature that came out last
November I think it was on the
appearance of various fossils and that's
not important right now
the important the important part of this
is it simply displays some things that
I'm interested in so here we have time
from the billions of years ago for 3 to
1 billion years ago and this is the
ocean originally it was an anoxic ocean
that is to say very little oxygen in the
ocean at all and it became a sulphate of
koushin which are many sulfate compounds
and oxygen in combination with sulphur
in the oceans and this allowed for many
more things to take place and finally
became an oxic ocean or one in which the
compounds were essentially compounds
with high with oxygen in it and were
could be very fertile in promoting life
and in the sky we have for example this
is the oxygen level we have first of all
very little oxygen at the beginning and
when the ocean turns sulfinic we have
the great event here of some particular
this disaster in terms of the fossils
that existed and also the proliferation
of great number of fossils and then what
that went up for a while so this is
let's say before you make organisms that
have nuclei in them and I should say
that many of you I recognize easily are
scientists and you will understand
exactly what I'm saying
and you might even get bored by what I'm
saying and I don't mind if you leave and
others among you are not scientist and
you may not understand you may not
understand what I'm saying but that
doesn't matter don't worry about the
scientific details the general things
that I'm saying are more important ok so
here we have bacteria before we have
eukaryotes and then eukaryotes start
coming in and around this time we have
in this paper was about these Gabon
fossils which apparently have something
like new
I in them and then that goes up until we
form the oxic atmosphere and we have a
whole series of other events occurring
right here that well right here we have
the oldest unequivocal animal fossils so
that's very recent only but let's say
800 million years ago now grandparents
myths some years ago proposed a theory
in which he suggested that clays were
very important in terms of the origin of
different simple organisms and I'll try
and describe this very briefly because
it's not apparent to me that it's that
relevant he said there there can be for
example two kinds of clays you can have
clays in which their crystals let's say
they were all pointed in this direction
or clays that if crystals are all
pointed in this direction like that I
don't disagree with that but then he
said that the other smaller molecules
that are absorbed on these Clay's can be
specifically fractionated in some ways
we know that in living organisms amino
acid residues which are part of proteins
make up one particular form of molecules
that reflect light and a certain fashion
ER I reflect polarized light in a
certain fashion and Karen Smith said
that well in these clays apparently the
amino acid residues which normally are a
mixture of let's say D and L amino acid
residues doesn't matter what they are
there both of them they can be
fractionated and one of the forms here
can remain on the Clay's and be and
participate in further reactions that
have some particular direction to them I
would say that the direction has
something to do with life and the other
form is lost completely okay that
without was a theory that was popular
with some people
and I don't think it has any real
seriousness behind it at all so I leave
that at that point it is still not clear
to us we do get separations of dnl amino
acids or for example d ribose is from
other ribose forms but all that does
happen and those are important problems
that we have to solve okay so I'm going
to start talking now about molecules
that I think are important in terms of
the genetic continuity of living
organisms now it is possible that
proteins have information and in fact
you can designate proteins so that
different points on them can be
represented as a bit of information but
from what I've said now what I will say
we don't have to pay attention to that
because proteins cannot reproduce
themselves in any particular way you
cannot take the information in proteins
and make more proteins with exactly the
same information from them only with the
original proteins and in fact we think
that RNA and DNA are probably the basic
genetic informational molecules and if
you look at DNA for example we know that
inside cells aside from one or two
viruses DNA is usually a double stranded
helix so we got two strands of a helix
winding around each other and it doesn't
exist in every in any other form you
could say that during replication of DNA
that there's a small region which is
denatured opened up but it's only done
not with proteins so we'll forget about
that but RNA is quite different RNA
exists is a single-stranded molecule
that is these are very long molecules
and they are made up of repeating
subunits and in one of your cells you
have approximately 1 meter of DNA
stretched out in one form if you stretch
out all the DNA
now since RNA can be single-stranded it
means various things one is that can
attain any shape it wants to in solution
that is there's nothing to inhibit RNA
from taking various shapes and side
solution and RNA has information in the
same way that DNA does and also as I
said has a repeated sequence of subunits
and that's about it and so that's all we
have to know at the moment now let's
just look at the chemistry of RNA and
this is probably more than you want to
know about the chemistry of RNA but
these are two of the subunits of RNA
this is the ribose ring or sugar ring
here and here and these are bases here
and here this is a purine base adenine
or guanine or a primitive base cytosine
to uracil and the sugar as I said is
here then there's a phosphate backbone
here and here now you can make various
derivatives of RNA which I'll mention
probably a little later
and once the phosphate backbone is is
substituted by different kinds of
phosphate backbones the sugars can be
substituted by different sugars and even
the bases can be substituted by these
spaces here and here supposedly all of
them can participate in hydrogen bonding
the point is that although there is a
RNA structure that we know about today
it's possible that at one point there
were structures that look like RNA which
may have contained some of these other
molecules and for example I think if
Cession Moser made an RNA with hexoses
six-member sugars here and they
participate in hydrogen bonding but they
didn't correspond at all to the melting
character
sticks that we know of of RNA let's just
say if you have two strands of RNA which
hydrogen bonded to each other and I'll
go into that a little while you can
supposedly melt them by heating them but
the hexoses didn't do that properly and
DNA just to indicate properly in terms
of the chemistry DNA only has a hydrogen
group here doesn't have the hydroxyl
just as a hydrogen group so DNA is
called deoxyribose which means no op c
in this position okay now this is an old
slide made by Hugh Robertson many years
ago unfortunately in my view very
unfortunately he died a few years ago
and this is to show some of the ways in
which you recognize pieces of RNA so
this could be just a long piece of RNA
and the number the letters we use here
simply indicate the abbreviation for the
bases in the RNA so we have a Cu and G
which are the four bases and you you can
have them specified along here and maybe
this is a signal of some kind but it
won't even say what it's a signal for
then we have secondary structure by
secondary structure I mean a way in
which pieces of RNA fold together to
make what looks like a double-stranded
structure so for example here you have
this sequence right here and then you
have in terms of Watson Crick hydrogen
bonding a complimentary sequence right
here so that you pairs with AC G au au
GC GC and you would have all this
hydrogen bonded which means it stays
together from let's say 30 degrees up to
maybe 50 degrees when you can melt it
but that's very important and this kind
of structure will not necessarily this
length but this kind of structural will
form sort of automatically in any piece
of RNA let's say that's a hundred
nucleotides long you will have self
complimentary regions in there
and they will form these double-stranded
structures that's very important as we
shall see later and then you can have
various other signals here for example
here you can have structure this is a
particular structure that might be
interesting this would be
double-stranded and some sequence out
here etc so this is all for people who
know something about nucleic acids very
simple but it's important just to know
that RNA does all these different things
ok so this is the iconic central dogma
as Francis Crick called it when he
enunciated it in the late 50s and early
60s and it represents the transfer of
information as we understand it today
and that is to say and this is not the
whole scene but this is the central part
of it you have DNA with genetic
information from that you can make RNA
and form RNA you can make DNA and RNA
then go to the ribosomes and it makes
proteins which have structure and
biochemical catalysis okay so all
biochemical catalysis was carried out by
proteins now when this was enunciated
and I should say revered one has to
assume that there were proteins at all
points in this case and everything that
I just mentioned was carried out by
proteins so that there is a protein
enzyme that replicates DNA DNA
polymerase replicates that there's
another protein enzyme called RNA
polymerase which copies DNA and makes
RNA from it and there's a reverse
transcriptase enzyme that all made of
protein the copies RNA in two pieces of
DNA and the ribosomes are made of RNA
and protein and we'll certainly talk
about them later but the point is this
only works if you have proteins present
to carry out all these reactions in 1967
was wrote a book about evolution and
Crick and Orgel separately wrote papers
about evolution and all three of these
people concluded that they had no idea
how life originated because they had no
idea how any of this happened in the
absence of protein and they made the
assumption that there was no protein
there could have been DNA and RNA at
that time but there was no protein so
this is a major puzzle which frickin
Brenner and excuse me Crick and Oracle
and wolves had to solve now here is
another view which first represents
exactly what I just said you have DNA
going to RNA but there's no future here
in terms of the beginning of life as
there are no proteins then in 1982 and
1983 some discoveries were made showing
that RNA could have chemical catalysis
okay so now we had RNA that had
information and biochemical catalysis
and now you have possible future because
he could say that you made small
organisms that hide our innate carry
information and RNA could carry out by a
chemical catalysis now what was done at
that time was something that scientists
invariably do you have this and at that
time was known that there were only two
reactions carried out by the RNA and
there were very simple reactions in
which RNA cut other pieces of RNA that
doesn't matter the idea is once you have
a reaction does something you can say
okay that molecule does that and
therefore we can assume that molecule
can do any kind of enzymatic function
it's a very broad statement and it's
always done by scientists when they
uncover new properties of a particular
category of molecules it's done by not
just biologists but by physics
- then in 86 while the Gilbert from
Harvard wrote a small opinion piece of
nature and he said well all this is fine
he said but in fact you don't need DNA
at all at this point
why have DNA present you don't need it
all you need is RNA
if RNA has information and it can carry
a biochemical catalysis say one thing it
could do is replicate itself I'd do
things like that and to do lots of other
things which we don't know about at the
moment then we'll just call this the RNA
world and that phrase the RNA world is
pretty much guided us and our theories
about ancient organisms up to this point
so that leads to a possible future in
terms of the origin of life now I should
say even though I've said that Wally
suggested this and that's what we use
the fact is we don't know whether or not
DNA was around or not we just don't know
we have no knowledge of it and secondly
while we say it's the RNA world the RNA
world could have consisted of many
derivatives of RNA like the ones I
mentioned earlier on so that it's not
exactly the RNA world we see at this
particular time now there are some
people who were stimulated to find
whether or not RNA could have other
enzymatic reactions I'm Larry Gould at
the University of Colorado invented a
technique which enabled people to do
this I'm going to show a slide from one
of his early papers but don't pay much
attention to it I'll just point out
what's important I hope ok you started
with a randomized template a randomized
piece of DNA or a piece of DNA that
could be made into RNA so you might have
a piece of RNA that's a hundred
nucleotides long
and by randomized we mean at every point
in that piece at every place where
there's a base sequence you
take this by Machine and you put on all
four bases at every point okay so you
might have a C c/g etc then you will
have g c c GG then you will have c GG c
see you have ug g CC and that will occur
at every point along the way and in that
sense you could very easily you can
prepare a half mil of a solution half
milliliter it's a very small amount of
solution with let's say easily a
trillion or more different sequences
available so that is very important and
it's a very useful tool so we have this
population and then we do a selection on
it that is to say if you have a
particular amino particularly enzymatic
reaction you're looking at let's say
that takes methyl groups ch3 groups and
adds them to something else
you can attach the ch3 group to a solid
support and put it on a call on just a a
linear representation of that stuff and
a solid support and pass the RNA
material you have over it and anything
that binds rapidly to that methyl group
will stick to the column everything else
just gets washed through and then you
can after you've done that you can raise
the salt conditions to some extent and
what's left bound to the column will be
washed through and you can do that many
times and make the aleutian properties
from the call and more more stringent
and finally you can wind up with one
molecule of RNA out of the many
trillions of them that in fact seems to
have the right properties and could be
what you thought of as having the proper
enzymatic properties so that was done
with many different enzymatic reactions
even though I haven't described that so
well and we have here a slide that was
made except for the last two lines about
15 years of ten or fifteen years ago
and which we have about 15 different
enzymes here all of them important for
life as we know that in bacteria today
and these were all isolated by various
people over the ensuing years from
Gold's original discovery of this method
seelix method and from that time they're
probably ten more isolated so people
let's say isolated about 25 different
enzyme functions all of which were due
to one particular piece of RNA and I
should say with that particular one
piece of RNA it's very easy to replicate
that many many times there's no problem
dealing with one molecule of RNA we're
dealing with millions and millions of
molecules of RNA that can do this
reaction so we have about 25 of these
that can happen and people got tired of
doing that and I don't blame them it's
very useful to have done it and it was
instructive now in addition to that
various molecules various pieces of RNA
were found what small molecules attached
to them for example a coenzyme a which
is an enzyme cofactor and that doesn't
seem to be too difficult to do and per
imitate and purine synthesis has
occurred now this is a very important
goal that was reached by John Sutherland
who was not the MRC lab of molecular
biology in Cambridge and he succeeded in
making purine and pyrimidine subunits of
RNA by doing it in essentially large
phosphate controlled essentially
reactions and he can do it essentially
in two or three days possibly even a
shorter time than that
this is the reactions that Crick and
Oracle were found to be virtually
impossible to do easily especially
Argyll who was a very good chemist and
he gave up because of that but
Sutherland has done this and I will do
nothing but congratulate him for what he
has done I think it's very important so
let's shift from a long time ago to
today
and here we have examples of catalytic
RNA today and by the way I should say
that none of those enzymes that are just
show you a min ago have been found today
they don't exist in nature as far as we
know or that is to say we haven't been
clever enough to find them in nature and
one can object to that in two ways one
saying we never had for example a
collection of a trillion different
molecules of RNA to work with which is
most probably true and we don't know
what time would take to sample such a
large number of molecules to see if they
had the right enzymatic conditions so
while people have found those enzymatic
conditions we have no idea whether or
not they exist today in fact so far as
we know they don't ok so here are
various examples there's the RNA subunit
of an enzyme called RNA speed which cuts
other pieces of RNA
there's Group 1 and group 2 introns I
won't explain what our intron is right
now I'll come to a little while for
group 1 introns founded by Tom Cech also
cut peat cut themselves in a certain way
plant viroid RNA and I'll talk about
that just briefly plant viroid RNA
single-stranded RNA which is a circle
it's a closed circle and it doesn't code
for any proteins it's usually about 350
nucleotides long and these are extremely
important as plant pathogens and for as
dangers to the commercial production of
plants virtually every plant that you
can think of that let's say fruit you
can see in a market and plants come from
that as a viroid which will attack the
plants and in fact you can take some
viroid RNA on your fingertips and rub it
into the leaf of a plant and three weeks
later four weeks later the plant is dead
that includes coconut palms and the
reason that your fingertips which
actually have nucleases in them that
degree
RNA don't attack this RNAs that the RNA
is a close circle so it's not easily
attacked by these nucleases then we have
hepatitis Delta RNA which is very
similar to plant viroid RNAs
this is sixteen hundred nucleotides long
again a close circle that codes for one
protein and it's important as a human
pathogen if you have hepatitis viral
hepatitis virus in your bloodstream you
get sick a little bit sometimes
occasionally that will transform into a
cancer but you do get sick from
hepatitis B virus however if you have
hepatitis B virus and hepatitis Delta
RNA you die within three weeks and the
mechanism by which this happens is not
fully understood at the moment so I'm
just saying this is a piece of
information that might be interested
then there's a fungal virus very similar
to these viruses ribosomal RNA
elongation site as many of you know
ribosomes were crystallized by Tom
States other people recently and if you
draw a sphere around the place in the
ribosomes where two amino acid residues
get joined together to mark the
continuation of a polypeptide chain
there is no protein in that sphere of
about 20 angstroms around that point so
the statement is made then that peptidyl
transferase and ribosomal RNA is an RNA
enzyme by itself and I should indicate
what an enzyme is I'll show you a slide
shortly but the fact is an enzyme is
something that carry aza carries out a
reaction and is not disturbed by itself
during the reaction so for example in
the old days when LED was in gasoline
lead was a catalyst that promoted the
explosion of gasoline mixture and LED
did not change during this reaction so
in this case this does not change during
the reaction in this case the RNA SP RNA
does no
interaction and then we have splicing
rnase you can make a complex of certain
splicing RNAs which are involved in
tailoring molecules with introns in them
and I won't talk anymore about them you
can make a reaction that looks as if
it's a natural reaction this is done by
Jim Manley and a woman who worked with
him and it seems to be a a reaction that
doesn't require any protein and finally
we have ribose witches which is they are
not really enzymes but these have been
discovered mainly by Iran breaker here
at Yale these are pieces of RNA that can
bind other very small molecules and say
vitamins or amino acid residues and they
are involved in regulating the
production of other things that the RNA
and codes would say anything more about
that but the ribose witches are
important in these ways and you put in
some way can include them in this
particular list okay so in biochemical
terms and enzymes are catalysts that
works in a chemical sense a gainer to
gain another class of molecules which
are called substrates and it is
unchanged by the reaction and so for
example there's an enzyme called
ribonuclease P and its substrate among
others are trna precursors and I'll talk
about this a little bit so here for
example is a transfer RNA precursor and
this is the way piece of RNA can be
drawn on paper these dots indicate
hydrogen bonds here here here they're
unimportant for us right now the
beginning of the transfer RNA which is
important and protein synthesis is it
this nucleate disposition which is
marked by one here we'll forget about
this for a moment and the RNA subunit of
ribonuclease p cuts this molecule right
at this point here and gets rid of all
these upstream sequences this is
important because when this
molecule is copied from DNA all these
nucleotides are included so rapid
nuclease P cuts right here now there are
about 60 different tRNA precursor
molecules on every cell type because
there are about 60 different ISO
accepting species of tRNA if you look at
the sequences around this site they're
not identical at all
so what else controls the specificity of
this enzyme for the substrate over
several years of work it was found that
the important thing is is simply this
apparently double-stranded region here
and the single-stranded region here so
the junction between a single-stranded
region and a double-stranded region here
is what controls the specificity of this
particular enzyme and as I said the
identity of these particular nucleotides
is not very important in fact you can
only have three or four of these base
pairs here and one nucleotide here and
the enzyme will still work so what else
is happening and that by the way has
been shown by many years of extensive
experimental data this is a speculation
based on that data which I just
mentioned and it has something to do
with the origin of life or it doesn't
have anything to the origin of life it's
just pure thought floating in the ether
so to speak you can have a large piece
of RNA to begin with okay and in this
large piece of RNA we have the supposed
hairpins that is double stranded regions
with loops and these are not uncommon at
all you have them frequently in large
pieces of RNA and then you have this
particular RNA subunit of RNA speed
which at that time would just be the RNA
subunit by itself and it cuts this
molecule right here at the beginning of
this hairpin and right here at the
beginning of this hairpin and right here
at the beginning of this hairpin so this
is speculation it simply says
that this particular enzyme has the
ability to cut this molecule in several
different places and molecules such of
this such as this we presume must have
existed many years ago when life was
extremely simple but once you cut this
into other pieces these other pieces can
have different functions as we know so
for example you can take this function
here and in fact you could add to that
CCA which we don't have to talk about
and you can add to that in fact an amino
acid which can then function and protein
synthesis and it has been used by Paul
Chimel and experiments to look at
protein synthesis and ultimately
although I will not say this is a strong
army by a by any chance you can get
duplication of this loop and then
finally a duplication of the loop again
or a similar loop and you get something
that looks like a transfer RNA molecule
so the specificity of this very ancient
enzyme can in fact be linked to
something that was very important a long
time ago but of course we don't know
anything about that I should say that
when you talk about RNA things like this
and the ability of RNA to replicate
itself if it did replicate itself we
know today for example that when RNA is
replicated mutations occur in it fairly
frequently by that I mean at the ratio
of 10 to the minus fifth or so four
rounds of replication whereas normally
what DNA doesn't occur to the
replication until ratios of 10 to minus
7 or 10 online safe but the point is RNA
can mutate even when replicated by an
enzyme but the point but the other point
is that DNA and RNA are chemicals and I
have to say that most students I speak
to don't understand that they see DNA
and RNA as diagrams on a page they're
not aware of their actual chemicals and
they obey all the laws of chemistry and
from that we know
that the base pairings in DNA and RNA
will change from time to time so even
without enzyme replication you will have
mutations in let's say RNA or DNA that
ultimately will lead to evolution of
whatever genetic material that you're
talking about so sorry that's a little
aside but let's go on this is a diagram
of the group on intron that have been
isolated by Tom Cech now if this is an
RNA molecule it starts here it goes here
and this zigzag line is part of it and
it ends here okay the point is for this
to be functional as we know it is in
this cases this part here has to be
joined to this part here and these are
called exons doesn't matter and this is
called an intron so we have to have ways
of getting rid of the syndrome and check
found that a molecule that he was
looking at this way which is a precursor
to a ribosomal RNA could in fact delete
this particular molecule from this
configuration and join this part to this
part here so he made this all it
certainly didn't have this little circle
in it here it just became aligned like
that plus the extra intron at this point
so that was also a very important
finding that RNA is catalytic okay so I
think I have to move along here now I'm
going to show another example of the
central dogma as we understand today and
this comes from another review article
that I think a peer - either a molecular
cell or cell okay it's tremendously
complicated but in fact it's not
complicated at all and this is what we
understand goes on right now here we
have DNA or chromatin which is the
condition in which DNA exists and higher
cells that is the chromosomes with
protein attached to the DNA and there
are small molecules called primer our
which helps in the replication of DNA
and we have telomeres which are the ends
of pieces of chromosomes and higher
cells not in bacteria and there's an
enzyme called telomerase which
replicates its DNA but that's not
important for about DNA and it goes in
to make RNA and part of the RNA is made
as messenger RNA which goes to ribosomes
and make proteins okay but what's all
this jazz here many different kinds of
RNA are appropriate or let's say listed
on this slide
and this is very important and I would
say and I'm going to be absolutely
patriotic in this sense to RNA if you
want to study something interesting for
the next ten years study RNA you will
get a good job and you'll find out
interesting things you can study other
things too but this is more important
okay so we have RNA you have RNA SP
which cuts transfer RNA T mRNAs
ribosomal RNA bacteria I won't talk
about these 7sl RNA which is in
eukaryotes you have snow rnas which cut
ribosomal RNA snrnas and then we have M
rnase micro rna's si RNAs and other
non-coding RNAs here not going to talk
about these three briefly and of course
aside from that we have messenger RNAs
which as I said make proteins but all
these other things do carry out
different functions inside cells and
they're very important in fact these
three are so important that it's worth
talking about them a little bit because
it indicates that RNA is extremely
important in controlling development and
differentiation okay we have non-coding
RNAs thousands of nucleotides long they
do not code for proteins and for most of
the functions are not known now one of
them is known the it's called the exist
iron
it's a few thousand nucleotides long
it's transcribed from one of the X
chromosomes and female cells and in
humans we know that females have two X
chromosomes males have only one but one
of the two X chromosomes and females is
inactivated it doesn't show any function
at all that's after a few rounds of
duplication of embryos so one of them is
inactivated and the same thing is true
for example in my son drosophila and
jeanne lee at the harvard med school has
been studying this for several years and
I have to say that she's done an
absolute marvelous job on this she's
done the biochemistry and genetics of
Xist RNA she looks she's looked at
various parts of RNA she's determined
that it that the exist RNA are parts of
it control the number of copies of X RNA
of the X chromosome and various other
things to have nothing but admiration
for her hot air RNA has been studied by
John Rin
who's at the Broad Institute in Boston
involved in oncogene expression and
there are many other RNAs involved with
epigenetic effects that is methylation
of DNA is still positioning so I would
say maybe there is another four or five
large non-coding RNAs have been found
for which some function is known but
these occur very frequently in higher
organisms and we don't know most of
their functions yet
now we also have Mi RNAs micro RNAs
these are small RNAs they can be up to a
few hundred nucleotides long but
ultimately they're processed into
something about 22 nucleotides long
although some of them can be somewhat
larger than that they were originally
found and seen her up titus elegans a
small worm and it was found that they
controlled certain developmental effects
in that worm and it was soon found that
a one of them for example was found also
in human cells and that the same thing
has been found about several of them and
it's absolutely clear that the
or rnase control differentiation and
development very important aspects of it
in higher organisms so we have now two
RNAs non-coding RNAs which are extremely
important as I said and the micro RNAs
and there are many micro RNAs in human
and mouse cells Drosophila scene Arab
Dittus and they control several
different differentiation effects and we
have RNA inactivation in which you make
larger RNAs a few hundred nucleotides
long that are double-stranded and they
can be processed into smaller RNA is by
process I mean there are certain enzyme
complexes and these cells shall cut down
these larger RNAs into smaller ones
many of them are micro RNAs and they can
function in in activating or activating
some genes in bacteria there are also
some small RNAs not going to go through
all of this at the moment but these
small RNAs let's say between 50 and 200
nucleotides long are responsive to
stresses that you put on the bacteria
for example by that and you have
bacteria generally growing at 37 degrees
you can grow them let's say at 25
degrees in some cases and the bacteria
have to adapt to the cold stress or you
can have them grow at 42 degrees they
have to adapt to the hot stress you can
change the pH that is to say you can
make the medium in which they're growing
very acidic are very basic and some of
these RNAs will appear so these are
stress responses and I think in many
ways that are not totally different from
the micro rna's we see in higher
organisms now
we're discovering new genes especially
to say among eye I wouldn't say genes
because genes generally mean coding for
proteins new mutations to aid providing
basic information but this has to do
with let's say the micro rna's and the
non-coding RNAs and at the molecular
level we essentially use everything
inside cells
many of the new RNAs we found especially
the non-coding RNAs are transcribed from
regions and cells that we thought were
non-functional that could have been junk
DNA or their regions in the non sense
strand and protein RNAs usually we have
a double stranded piece of DNA that
codes for a particular protein then the
other strand quotes for another could
code for another protein and that's what
we found now and it is important for us
to understand the function of these
additional RNAs and in fact the RNAs
that are made from supposedly junk
regions so I think that's terribly
important at the moment what I'm saying
here is that effectively you shouldn't
neglect anything if you're studying
molecular biology of information
transfer in cells nothing is a material
nothing is unimportant everything that
you're looking at is important and it's
worth studying okay I think I only have
a couple of slides left this is about
the evolution of the RNA subunit of RNA
SP and I'll talk about that in a second
I just want to recapitulate for a second
I wound up saying that it's totally
unclear how life originated or virtually
totally and then it seemed as if it was
more or less obvious that I had to start
with RNA and I've talked about RNA since
then as being important in one way or
another and the more I've talked about
it the more
important it has become up until where
we are today and just as a coda I'll
mention this is an example of evolution
of one of its problems so one of one of
its many problems that want to present
today in this case in bacteria this
enzyme as one RNA subunit and one
protein subunit and it's catalytic
activities let's say we can define as
between 1 and 10 and archaea which is
another kingdom of supposed bacteria
defined by karl was very important
there's an RNA subunit of the enzyme and
there are four protein subunits and the
amount of catalytic activities between
10 to the minus 1 and 10 to the minus 2
compared to this in eukaryotes which are
essentially people like us or released
there are nine to ten protein subunits
and the amount of catalytic activity in
the RNA by itself is 10 to the minus 5
compared to this so if you draw an
evolutionary tree this is sort of the
beginning this is almost the beginning
and this is much later on now we see as
evolution goes on that the amount of
catalytic tivity having to do with the
RNA subunit appears to decrease or
that's the way we measure it and the
amount of proteins has increased so the
question is how did this happen do the
proteins actually have catalog activity
by themselves or are they simply
enhancing the RNA subunit which i think
is most likely what happens in this
particular case and that's a problem
which should be asked in these days and
I think there are people working on our
now I hope that will remain the case
lastly there is one other slide that I
made up yesterday which i think is worth
mentioning don't laugh
okay we started with the RNA world and
then for a while we talked as if there
is a protein world today and all the
enzymes which are important in
replication of nucleic acids and many
other enzymatic reactions are made up of
protein but I think of the last few
years we can change them and as a again
I am a partisan in this sense I'm a
strong partisan we still have the RNA
world because RNA clearly is extremely
important and regulating controlling
genes that have something to do with
development and we have a protein world
course this is in smaller levels
compared to RNA at the moment that's
just my partisanship showing through
finally we have a question mark and that
is the next description of our world I
have no idea what that will be and if
anybody has a reasonable suggestion I'm
willing to listen thank you
okay questions
thank you a very simple question of
anyone of people who work in labs know
that you have to take so many extra
precautions working with RNA because
it's so easily degraded where's you know
you can isolate DNA out of anything
without conscience can you give any
little insight about if the earn a was
also what might be the mechanism for
wanting to get rid of the RNA really
quickly in an you know we know
developmental context if you don't want
it around like what is it degrade so
rapidly any any why are we getting rid
of RNA why do you think we're getting
rid of RNA I don't think we're getting
ready for I don't think we're getting
rid of RNA Thank You dr. Harmon so you
mentioned in the beginning that you
thought the building blocks of life was
something that has DNA and replicate
itself exactly so I was wondering if you
consider viruses life and whether or not
your definition of life can be also
extrapolated onto other planets because
given your ingredients that could
potentially happen and with proteins
being the basic building blocks of life
which you see DNA also being used as
encoding protein production on other
planets as well okay I don't believe
viruses are organisms of life as I
defined them because viruses cannot
replicate by themselves they only
replicate inside other cells right and I
don't know what happens on other planets
I have no idea you mentioned that
proteins are not self-replicating if
fundable you are not self-replicating
and how do the problems fit into that
prions are proteins that are thought to
be involved in scrapy and other such
diseases and it had been thought for
some time that they did self replicate
but they don't sell for locate if you
read papers by you don't have to read
them by Charles Weissman or cosigner you
will find that the prions are different
and Confirmation and their structure and
solution and a normal prayin makes
normal pronouns with the right
conformation if they're put in solution
with a prion that comes from a diseased
person ultimately the diseased prion
which is on different conformation will
bind to some of the normal proteins and
induce them to become abnormal in
structure - so what's being replicated
is this flux and of the molecule
inflammation I wouldn't say it's being
replicated but in fact the unusual
structure gets transmitted in some way
but it's not part of the genetic
material right here oh sorry yes
I thank um a question which is regarded
to your comment that you're very
patriotic about
R&A well in the scientific community
which is working on these issues would
you say that this odd does that play a
role I mean other people who were DNA
patriotic and focus to try to defend the
DNA is there is ideologic playing role
in the scientific community in these
matters I really interested that I mean
thanks could you could repeat that last
sentence you said um this test idea
logic thinking plays the role yes yes
securely emotional completely emotional
I'm just trying to generate more support
for RNA that's all and probably there
are a lot of people here would disagree
with me about that um you talked about
how important RNA as an enzyme was in in
the B in simpler forms of life why why
would you say you know as an RNA patriot
why would you say that the proteins take
over more and more of the enzymes if RNA
is efficient well that's a very good
question because it brings up two things
one is first where there are so many
enzymes associated with RNA to begin
with which we can say is possible but we
don't really know it's the case the
second question is when did proteins
start being made and they had to be made
at some point and there are some
theories now about how RNA could begin
to make simple proteins and then the
question is why did proteins turn out to
be so much better at these functions
compared to RNA now that's not entirely
true because some some proteins are
clearly better there is no RNA form that
carries out a lot of these functions but
some of the functions are still carried
out by RNA so RNA themselves like RNA SP
and which is a very important enzyme
it's essential in all cells
does all kinds of interesting things and
for example in the ribosome where
supposedly the peptidyl transferase is
critical so I have no real answers to
your questions but it's important to
consider what still remains from the RNA
world and what has changed and we don't
know how what has changed happened you
talked about synthesis of bases and
sugars how about how do you synthesize
RNA how do we make I mean in in a be a
pretty otic world yeah that's exactly
what John Sutherland is working on at
the moment and I say that having heard
him speak about a month ago at a meeting
he's clearly intent on making long
pieces of RNA from these purines and
pyrimidines he's able to make he makes
that he makes the whole nucleotide the
sugars with the bases attached to them
so it just has to figure out how to put
them together to make long pieces of RNA
and that's what he's working on I can't
tell you any more about that how about
how about dr. faeries how about whom I'm
sorry I don't quite understand you he
was making RNA on clays on clay yeah
yeah so I thought you've had a no I
don't put much attention to those
particular experiments reason well we
can we can talk about that for a bit
said all of this requires energy
something moves are we looking at a
phosphate are we looking at a toxic
water oh [ __ ] fate oh yes yes obviously
that has to be important in terms of
making the the nucleotides and John
Southern and in bits it's very important
one of the steps that he uses involves
UV radiation and I asked him why he did
that and he said that's because
literally always did it Leslie Orgel did
it
and so that supplies a certain amount of
radiation but we're over but we're only
talking about nucleotides right now and
you can argue about some of the other
sources of energy to do other things
there are lots of geochemists who feel
that iron sulphide complexes which are
present many proteins are very important
to but we still have to wait and see
what comes out from these experiments